hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
the great work ok I got a rose here and
someone said I need to combine something
in here before I do anything else so I
need to make sure that I get what I got
and get it the way where we go and I
need to get it the way I get it to get
it to where I need to go so let's try a
few combinations here ah ok heated that
up and I need to be able to do stuff
with it until I get to where I need to
go maybe I need to extract yes put the
glass jar here and no no oh god is this
gonna be another sequence of failures oh
boy
ah the chemistry pot got it nail it
aha Carmon okay karma a lot of you
people are making fun of me just cuz I
didn't realize that I read the word car
MOT and I didn't know what car MOT was
all about Alka yeah oh hello ah goodbye
ah didn't hear anything uh-huh how long
is that sad you been there has that
always been there ha good thing I got
that chair there
Oh gave up ha ha ha good yeah you didn't
wanna mess with me mousse man
that's the mousse man I can tell by the
antlers ok so I got a legendary solvent
of incredible strength that I need to
make sure that I do what I need to do
and Lord do it that way I don't know
chart is fused with my body is that the
only thing that I need from here is that
all that seems to be the only thing in
here that I could possibly need unless
somehow I can put this back ok no ok so
we're all done with this Thank You chair
for blocking that up and I saw a baby I
don't know how long you were there but
if you were always there then good what
the watch has been been what what oh
what the hell get me higher well how do
I
well that doesn't cut Oh
ah I thought for sure I need to blow the
ha oh come on it's right there I see it
ah Oh what legendary solvent and what is
going on here why can I use that right
there god damn it
[ __ ] hell Jesus what ha what the [ __ ]
I'm Adam at times why that suddenly
we're done what I don't even yeah okay
whatever okay work to work to work them
go for it I'm going for whatever up or
down up or down down I guess of course
I'm going down I'm not going up what the
hell what the hell man game maker come
on you realize that when people try
something once they'll usually give up
on it
if they can't get it to work and I was
tried like oh man oh man you guys don't
know I cut out a lot there I was oh ah
ha ha oh no oh no oh come on
okay at least I'm here and at least I'm
at full health okay that was just a
super-secret trick that I did for all
you amateur gamers out there
protip die you going full health
somehow oh man
okay I was just kind of pissed off
because of how long that took I was like
oh god damn I knew it had something to
do with the flammable gas but there was
this that I think it was just like that
one itty-bitty part of the drivers fully
wound okay why for what purpose there's
one itty-bitty part of that pipe I guess
it was right next to that candle but I
mean come on what do we got here mark
puzzles
more puzzles okay can't move them I
can't move them I cannot they are stuck
okay so this is apparently part of the
clockwork machinery don't eat a mess
with that one I've thought heard some
hey let's go into the clockwork as
hartleb concentrated on the stone he
suddenly became aware of the universe
information poured into his oh I've
already read that before information
poured into his mind and back out again
Maureen hello giant clockwork stuff very
cool there's a ladder there okay don't
think I need to go there just yet
the key driver oh man there's got to be
an unbelievably complicated puzzle isn't
it oh god it's not that these puzzles
are hard so far it's just they have very
strict requirements like very small
windows as which they work
so I don't know I don't know man I just
don't know okay who's this Frankie D
cranky cranky cranky cranked don't he
does cranky - cranky - cranky crankily
pouring
and any manner
oh yeah we go whoo hello and the light
came on - what's over here
some
what the hell is that why am I going
towards it ah hose that statue again ah
right now he's looking at a statue
thanks babe for distracting him what's
going on there hi it's alive not fair
I'll go up the chain huh I'll go down
the chain he was a target on her like oh
[ __ ] don't go down the chain don't ever
go down the chain [ __ ] what was going on
there that was like weird house like
SuperDuper weird harder harder yeah
maybe you gotta sneak around him oh
they're gone a little lover's circle man
there's something wrong with those
statues now I thought the statues were
cool bro statues are not cool bread
okay okay okay got it
nailed it oh man that was weird how is
this weird I don't know what wha but I
thought you go okay anywhere I gotta go
see what's in this ladder over here why
game those are the only status' I liked
those are the only ones I liked is
you're taking that away from me this
isn't fair this isn't fair
this isn't fair you're not fair game
you're not fair
there was one statue that I liked and
now I do not like them what's it's down
here is there anything I need down here
I wanna get out of here that looks gay
bleached what is down here why am I
going down here why am i doing anything
here okay
what's this all okay I see so apparently
I didn't need to come down here at all
okay
I'm okay not okay
huh the one statue that I was totally
okay with hahaha cam okay
one statue that I was totally okay with
that didn't scare me at all now I do not
like the statue seems to have powers
over the Moosman mood man you okay my
woman okay all right okay let's go up
the chain huh
okay go up into the abyss I go down into
the abyss I go up into the abyss either
way I'm going into the abyss okay this
looks nice weird chain climbing sounds
sounds like someone's banging on metal
oh whoa whoa whoa what the hell you just
dropped me off into nothingness what the
[ __ ] was that screw you buddy what the
hell there's nothing here dude dude man
there's nothing here nothing here bruh
what are you doing to me what are you
doing to me
there's nothing here bro there's nothing
here I can't even stand on the ledge
that you're throwing me out on seriously
there's nothing here why do you want me
to get off on this stop haha okay
alright I'm on the ledge but seriously
there's there's nothing here I don't
even see where the chain went is this a
bug
hang on ha ha ha
maybe I just got to the top of the chain
maybe I wasn't supposed to go up this
high hand maybe I need to get off at a
different level oh man this game is
confusing me
let's game don't make shunts this game
don't make no sense
it is exactly nonsensical why is this
here maybe it was just a kid away from
the monster maybe that's it maybe there
was no other purpose to it besides a
hiding place from the monster I wasn't
supposed to die I was supposed to just
be able to hide from it a little bit I
don't know
wow I am I am dumb ah how did these get
undone Oh what up what the bollocks I
did this and then I died
okay so let's try this old okay now okay
something happened
I shouldn't die i should not die what
let's try going up this again haha I'm
like utterly confused what is the dealio
okay once again there's nothing up here
there's nothing here another here you
dingbat
there's nothing here you dingus unless
that's a little hole no that's not okay
I'm going down what do I do
do I go back out then I know I know what
this game won from me
give me clear directions I don't know I
don't know I don't know okay all right
so oh now the clockwork is moving up
there okay so that's good right that's
good okay so now I need to get to that
door have an idea if I jump off this
ladder and somehow get on that clockwork
stuff I can I can get to where I need to
go hang on
maybe maybe haha
[ __ ] no there's got to be a way
hang on what do I do with this ladder
here this ladder seems pretty useful I
need to get on the clockwork now that
it's turning although I think it was
turning before but whatevs
whatevs I ain't going judge yeah damn
dingus I'm gonna die again and then all
my progress is got to be researched
I don't know I don't know what this game
wants from me I don't know what I'm
doing here I don't even know why ah Pro
epic proneness to the level extreme I'm
super proud you can't touch my proneness
I don't know if I can make that jump ha
what the oh come on
ball shot I know this game to make me
angry but that's only because I'm bad at
puzzles damn it I thought I had dad why
did I fall off I think I've moved off I
can't oh man this is gonna be impossible
isn't it it's gonna be frickin
impossible try again
good thing I can take unlimited fall
damage when I need to
sounds like the mass effect music okay
just imagine it's a wheeler-dealer okay
here we go
here we go ha boom aah
I don't know if I was supposed to do
that but I don't care [ __ ] it I'm moving
forward we're moving forward okay here
we are
so I've got my legendary oh boy I've got
my legendary solvent and I turned on the
clockwork mechanisms all the doodads and
bojangles so
what's down here
I'm badly damaged there's something in
here with me I don't have any law Donna
dumb what was that what was that what
happened what happened they claimed to
have made the perfect homunculus but
it's nothing but an abomination they
ripped the heart out of a living human
being and force it to do their bidding
their minds are no longer their own but
have instead been replaced by something
more sinister
they single-mindedly hunt down the other
shards and by extension myself a mentor
temple barely escaped with my life heart
still part of that monster the hearts of
the monsters they used to be been now
replaced by glowing charts okay it beats
it beats in my hand a reservoir of life
for that abomination like the monsters
themselves the fly's flesh cannot be
pierced with a knife I must complete the
outcast if I can destroy the heart the
Beast will die I have outcast now I need
to destroy this is what he wanted me to
find I have to destroy the heart okie
dokie okie dokey smokey now what do I
need to do about that oh I should not
make noises Oh what uh it's an angel
wing that's weird are you moving did you
just move thought I moved okay so
there's something that I need to find
where am I gonna find it where am I
gonna find it okay is there nothing on
the shelves that I need there is nothing
there's nothing I'm actually afraid that
I might have skipped some and worked up
the game might've who knows certainly I
do not know I don't know anything that
I'm doing if I barked the game I
apologize okay come on
man you do not want to give me ten aha
Ted no box but not many do you
nothing there than there than there okay
what's with the purpose of these rooms
if for not okay
more clockwork machinery aha I need to
find a gear for that door maybe I
shouldn't because there seems to be
something behind that door are these
okay the machinery isn't working I need
to go get one of the cogs from the other
the other side of the room I'm trying to
save oil I know the path here okay this
come here you're coming with me all
right
nothing scary just wandering in the dark
with the cogwheel yeah
oh now I understand what's happening I
gotta try to get this door open
come here come here come here come on
let me let it out where am i what am i
doing what am i doing goddamn it huh huh
huh where am I
Burma Burma MOCA okay come here come
here
uh-huh which way over down up or down up
up up down down down down down down down
down down down down down down down down
ah ah drop [ __ ] huh
real real real real okay MA oh come on
spin back then fucking's been holy balls
hard I got a
I killed it he killed it
who killed it I killed it I killed it I
killed it I killed it I killed it I
killed it I'm the man
Oh God I killed it I killed it
I killed it I killed it I killed it
I killed it okay okay ah choke before
oh this looks perfectly nice how did I
get here I was climbing up a ladder
okay all right that's enough for that's
enough for today
that's enough forever okay so that's it
for now I'll pick this up at a later
time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotations for more
videos hit I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye